James Altucher is a he's a prolific man
this guy he's got a podcast this guy is
and as an author this guy is an
incredible businessman and I say
incredible in the sense that he's made a
ton of money you got lost just as much
and then made of ton a ton of money and
then lost it again and then made it in
law it's amazing it's amazing his story
but he's also a and I had no idea
because I knew who James Altucher was I
did not know that you guys have like a
childhood history together
yeah 42 year old 42 year history that's
amazing that I just thought your age no
I'm everyone knows I'm 15 I would say
close buddy goes back to about fourth
grade yeah it's right around there Wow
fourth grade I remember that I remember
the day you moved in you know to town I
remember you the first day in class
fourth grade you were cracking non-stop
jokes I don't know if it was like cuz
you were nervous you know you were the
new kid in town boy and it was mrs.
Osborne she even said you should be like
a comedian oh yeah that's right mrs.
Osborne was my teacher that's cool
forgot about that are you excited when
you found out your teacher was mrs.
Osborne probably but you spelled the
difference she spelled it Oh sbor any I
think yeah yeah she was sexy though I
liked her she was cute I saw her at the
pool once oh really nice yeah yes was
Jim oh did you know Jim to be a weird
kid well like I mean I get he was funny
but like the stories that we've heard
about his childhood here which I don't
even know if if those stories leaked out
into school if people realize oh that
was a new town yeah you tried it on he
talks about third grade yesterday right
Brian he moved in in fourth grade so no
more Jimmy sucks now that we're coming
oh yeah yeah Jimmy duck stick sucker
stayed in Edison okay I see Jimmy cool
[ __ ] Hannah moved in north you're like
new town new Jimmy no more sucking dick
I'm nine years old it's time for me to
retire from second put my mouth and the
Hall of Fame and I didn't exactly retire
you postponed it probably played senior
league you know different though not not
that many kids are obsessive kids Jim
was obsessed with kiss for instance sure
and you know being obsessed with
anything a young age is kind of
different it sets you apart like most
kids are just sort of playing along
following the rules doing what they can
to fit in Jim was just like
you loved kiss every single day I was
obsessed and obsessions a good thing for
a kid yeah I think so I think that it
ends up like I think when little kids
are obsessed and they don't break out of
it they end up doing something creative
with it right yeah like I wish my kids
were more obsessed with with things
instead now kids are so forced into like
Oh score high on your state exam so the
teachers give homework till 2:00 in the
morning you don't have time to be
obsessed anymore and that's the key the
key that creativity the key to being a
little different no one creates
something new unless they're a little
different right and then they go to
college right and they're penny they're
paying $50,000 a year and they're
shocked when they don't know what they
want to do when they leave school but
it's because they feel like when you're
obsessed with something or multiple
things like your mind works in that way
where you're allowing yourself to kind
of go in the direction that you actually
want to go in whereas when you're when
you're just kind of doing what you're
told you're like okay let me concentrate
on this test let me let me get to this
grade let me go there right if you're
going down with the process and there's
your nowhere what you're just waiting
for the next thing to be told
rightly if your goal is to get an A and
all you're doing is studying to get that
a first off it's not gonna get into
long-term memory because you're cramming
and then it disappears so nobody
actually remembers anything from college
was just that's a scam in itself then
you know an eighteen year old can borrow
$200,000 no problem I can't I don't
think I can borrow $200,000 no prob but
an it but I can or I can do something no
eighteen year old can do I can order a
Budweiser at a bar an eighteen year old
kid an eighteen year old could borrow
two hundred thousand dollars and then
also go drive a tank in Afghanistan I
can't do either of those but an eighteen
year old can buy a beer right right
what's the most money you've lost
probably about 20 20 men there was once
owned a million dollars and I don't say
this to brag because the end result was
that there was one summer I was losing a
million dollars a week and I really
thought I mean I ended up the end of
that summer with a hundred forty-three
dollars in my ATM and I was like
panicking so much because I had built up
to this lifestyle and I had two babies
so I Anna the good thing was I had a
life insurance policy
I got when I was at the top and that my
kids were baby so I was thinking you
know what it'd be they won't remember me
but they'll have you know millions and
millions of dollars if I could figure
out how to kill myself without the life
insurance company knowing because you
couldn't you know if you suicide they
wouldn't get the money so I just kept
trying to search all these solutions
like how can you kill I didn't want to I
didn't want it to be known it was a
suicide and I didn't want to hurt myself
that's how you want to do it like park
your car and pretend you didn't know
there's [ __ ] stuff and a hose in the
back that the proud I've research that
the problem is a lot of people end up
just like you know kind of in a
semi-coma for the rest of their lives
like I didn't want to end up like that
I'd be like oh in the in the exhaust one
yeah yeah and you can't like you can't
also you can't put a gun in your mouth
because I've know cases where you just
shoot out your eye in your ear and get
paralyzed sure that's not fun either if
you were depressed of a given way let's
try to hide that as a suicide attempt
funny cuz you didn't know I was there I
was at the Comi saw a few weeks ago and
you did a suicide joke where you like
throwing yourself in front of a train
and and you like what if you mess up and
you just have like this like you know
you're like limping and have this like
scarred face and everything that's not
pleasant afterwards right like a failed
suicide attempt is the worst way to live
your life yeah right it's embarrassing I
couldn't I actually did figure it out
and one time I was doing comedy and my
lawyer was in the audience and he said
don't do that any any more how did you
figure it out I I did figure out Mom
following my little only time I'll ever
follow my orders advice like I don't
want anybody to go try this because it's
really easy actually and I'm gonna try
this you probably wanna keep in your
back pocket just use everything it's the
safe way so I had comprehension we have
the company that you illusion $29 and
while we losing 20 million a week well
I'm sorry million week yeah I sold this
is like in the late 90s I sold I wait I
made websites for corporations before
they had any websites and so I was like
the first website for American Express
calm and then you could tell by the way
I look and everything I did the websites
for every gangster rap record label and
so I sold that company and then there
was into the stock went up and so I had
all this stock and I sold the stock I
was smart I sold it like the top and had
cash
and then I think figured you know what
this internet thing is here to stay and
I would just but I was there was 1999 I
was just the stupidest investor in the
world I would invest in things like oh
here's a portal for left-handed athletes
let's put like a million dollars into
this and I was just stupid that was just
like really stupid there's there's like
three skills making it keeping it
growing it so at the time and for a long
time I only knew how to make it I didn't
know how to keep it or grow it yeah so
you're sitting there and you're this is
the first time your life you've had this
kind of money
yeah that's zero and then suddenly I
sold my company for millions like I was
broke and sold my company for and
suddenly I had money and you don't have
the mentality of okay I have money I
just have to stay here and I'll be good
instead you're like wow now I'm a guy
with money I can spend it all and I'm
gonna have even more coming back right
cuz you think you know money you know
society sort of blesses money with
something more than it is and so you
think oh I have money so I must be smart
yeah and so I thought oh I'm the
smartest person in the world if I can
make it here I can make it anywhere so I
just figured anything I touched would
turn into gold and I didn't think if
this is a one-time chunk that I'm
winning the lottery in this Internet
boom I just figured you know okay this
is like my salary now it's like my new
income right and it just didn't work
that money doesn't work that way no the
worst company ID you've had there had to
be one you're like oh I was [ __ ]
hideous yeah I had an idea that was one
time it was like a hot or not you know
how to not say you vote hot or not and
then they made it like a dating site
kinda good what they did so I I figured
okay let's do something similar but more
more what relevant to people so I did
smart or stupid and so I would have men
and women take an IQ test before
uploading their photo and fax I built
the company and built the website and
everything and my six-year-old daughter
at the time comes up to me he's like
isn't that kind of mean to people and
you know then people would vote
beforehand they would see a woman's
picture of a man's picture this guy's
smart or stupid and then you would see
their IQ results it was just the
stupidest idea ever on the planet right
it didn't do well it no because who's
gonna take an IQ test and then upload
their photos
like yeah but and then I had some ideas
that that were good but I just wouldn't
follow up on them because I just
constantly had personal issues too right
yeah I mean I was I was reading your
book yesterday I was reading choose
yourself and like in the beginning
you're talking about like just
everything I'm sitting there and I go
you know you always read these books
about people in their struggle time and
you're like it's not okay you can get
through that and like it feels like the
fact that you went through this multiple
times there are multiple points in your
life where you had made money and then
you lost everything and while this is
all happening you know you become
estranged from your parents right yeah
and your dad passed away yeah before you
started talking to him again yeah so
that's got to [ __ ] you up then
everything starts to look like it's
getting better you start making money
again then you lose everything again
yeah second thing so I built up another
company sold that for millions but two
houses you know thought again um I'm a
genius again and lost all of that
learned nothing from the first time
right lost all that got divorced and you
know block with that divorce no knows
good it was you know because you know
just the mother of my children so I
wanted to be a good guy and everything
and so I basically whatever we I left
went her we divorced at the right time
because you divorced when you lost
everything right yeah I gave her like
all the houses and stuff like that and
but I had no cash or anything left I was
like busy living like on the floor of a
holiday and you know to survive I
remember Thanksgiving I went literally
to a diner to have like a turkey
sandwich and before that I put in I put
an ad on Craigslist and it was it was a
you know what anybody would do when they
went broke I put an ad on Craigslist and
I said I was I had a brain injury and
then after I got out of the brain injury
after I got out of the coma I was found
out that I was psychic so please anybody
out there you could ask me any question
I want on this Thanksgiving and I go out
for turkey sandwich come back there's
like hundreds of emails and people just
asking like the most random
and so I separated them into two piles
the emails from men the emails from
women I deleted all the emails from men
and I started responding to all these
emails as how I spent the first
Thanksgiving you know you didn't charge
people you did it for free i and IIIi
did charge you and I cuz I cuz I I had a
goal which was to meet someone no I see
and but I admitted to everybody I wasn't
psychic but I did develop these huge
email like most of the emails from women
were like I'm attracted to somebody I
work with what should I do
and so those also would get deleted I'm
still Facebook friends with actually did
you meet anyone no out of it yeah yeah
oh I didn't I didn't meet anybody where
it worked out but I did meet some of
them in person just right for lunch or
whatever to see yeah and I would pursue
and I got rejected every time did you
yeah because I was a broke lying psychic
right right none of that stuff you said
I had to happen to you right it's not
true right was the one that you thought
you had potential with and she found
that you were broken not a psychic in
lost interest I never you know one would
ever say that but who knows you know I
definitely wasn't living like a healthy
lifestyle at the time so right and and
did the divorce come because your wife
is like this is clearly like a cycle
with you like he may lose everything
like you're completely irresponsible
maybe I mean to her credit she wanted a
more sane and organized life and I was
definitely chaotic like you never could
at that time in particular like I could
be doing anything on any day and losing
money making money losing all the money
on and borrowing more we might be
impossible to be around you were losing
money or did you just kind of hand it
like at whatever [ __ ] it I can handle it
now I couldn't handle it then I would
get really get suicidally depressed then
and now I can handle it like you know
you asked earlier what's the most or you
asked most what's the most I've lost so
one time another business I lost and
basically went broke I lost nine million
in a day and and I went totally broke
again how do you lose nine million
dollars in one day because I had stock
in this one company and like overnight
they went bankrupt and I was on the
board too it was a whole
a whole case and but then I was on I was
on the set of one of my favorite TV
shows like watching how is this TV show
was getting shot and I had seven hours
left of the shoot to watch and so I
figured you know what forget it I'm just
gonna watch this and deal with the going
broke again tomorrow and that is a much
better way to make your money back is if
you kind of bounce back because if
you're just depressed you can't make any
money if you're if you're active and
having ideas and diversifying your ideas
and opportunities then that's the
fastest way to make money back but you
have to be healthy for that you got to
be creative for that you can't be
depressed for that so I I realized that
that was the way to make it back and
then keep it and then grow it and that's
that was a big switch for me so how do
you click back in for the third time
then after that so now I'm just I just
diversify everything I do so and and the
trick is in addition to being creative
all the time the trick is to never think
you're smart so too I always assume I'm
the stupidest person in the room so I
don't invest in anything unless there's
like some billionaire investor who I
know has done he's six thirty PhDs on
this company before I even looked at it
and I'm investing alongside him and then
I'll say okay take a tiny bit of my
money not a little a lot because if
something's good a tiny bit will turn
into a lot and and then I could sleep at
night too but if something's bad and I
put in a lot and I don't have a
billionaire investor to call to say hey
what's going on then I'm just never
gonna sleep at night so you've written a
ton of books twenty-one books right yeah
a twenty-one books you've got your
podcast
most of them bad I don't recommend most
of them no what's the worst one I wrote
one called super cash where I had like a
it is like in 2006 I had all these
investing strategies that hedge funds
were doing and they just turned out to
be all really bad strategy and and some
of these hedge fund managers ended up in
jail like they're doing these crooked
strategies right sorry
but I figured like oh no they're talking
to me so it must be good so they like me
and I was just like writing chapters
about all their different like corrupt
strategies I didn't had no
khlo you know it was corrupt yeah that's
just when did you figure out that
business because I feel like that's such
a big business now is like people who
have some success or have this level of
expertise or whatever it is and the new
business is trying to teach other people
you know what I mean how to do it yeah
so the business I have now it's kind of
like that yeah I kind of help other
people figure out their own you know how
to stand next to the smartest person in
the room so you can make good decisions
not just about investing but if you want
to write a book or if you want to start
a business on the side or if you want to
you know learn about you know new things
like crypto or real estate or whatever
so that's that's a good business and
again it's how I diversify so that's a
business it's grown pretty big in the
past since I started from profitable
from day one I always like to be
profitable now so that I know you know
if you're making profits you're helping
somebody so and if the profits are
growing word of mouth is spreading and
you're helping more people so I always
those are the best types of businesses
but I don't I don't like working that
much so investing is a much better right
like if I see you know oh Mark Cuban's
investing in something it's much better
for me to just say okay let him do the
hard work and I'm just gonna write a
check I just follow him yeah yeah I just
do what he's doing like nine years later
hopefully I'll get a check back do you
think Bitcoin is gonna go back up past
its peak oh yeah yeah I really yeah like
like now like the story hasn't changed
it's just that it was in a bubble at the
end of last year it's it's still the
same change like what's the great thing
about you know every kind of evolution
of money solves problems of the previous
version of money so right now with paper
money somebody Washington DC could make
a decision about the money in your
pocket that you have no choice in like
they could print an extra trillion
dollars and you're the value of your
money just went less in your pocket or
they could or if you transfer money to
Jim the IRS and the FBI can see the
transaction friends or family sure you
know so you know Bitcoin solve some of
these major problems like how do you you
know transfer money more privately how
do you it more securely how do you know
exactly what's happening with your
currency like nobody could print just on
a whim extra Bitcoin James I jumped in
at the height of the bubble and I've
lost 75 percent
my investment well just just hold on
okay that's a good time to buy it I I
can't I can you know I don't like to
give advice at all so I can't answer
that but I like Bitcoin so I'm owning it
but you're following Mark Cuban I'll
follow you so I don't know what mark
even thinks about Bitcoin though oh boy
but there's other smart people who like
it but some smart people who hate it
but then you look at like the smart
people who hate it like Jamie Dimon from
is the head of JP Morgan he says he
hates it and yet JP Morgan's like
implementing all this Bitcoin stuff so
who do you believe but you can't buy it
from like your broker right you have to
go on an app and get it
yeah which is what I don't like that
aspect of Bitcoin so so like soon
they're gonna make or there is you know
getting better and better exchanges like
the New York Stock Exchange the started
this exchange back to bak KT where you
can do it now I think you can't call
your broker most infidelity starting
their own exchange so you could call
your fidelity broker and buy it but
again I'm not recommending anything one
way or the other I'm just saying it's
like the Internet in 1996 no one will
put their credit card on the Internet in
1996 by 2002 we all we were like begging
to put our credit card and the Internet
so it's just things change over years I
don't know how Bitcoin works it's been
explained to me I have no clue as to how
it worked I can go to an ATM and get the
cash out I guess but like yeah there are
Bitcoin ATMs but yeah and like but
that's just it nobody knows how Amazon
works like no one would say Amazon is
this program built on top of the TCP IP
Internet Protocol people say Amazon's a
store so eventually people say bitcoins
the form of money you don't have to know
exactly nobody knows how the Federal
Reserve works and yet people still true
but use their money so it's the same
thing and now I think Wyoming is saying
they might accept taxes in Bitcoin so
stuff like that's just like beginning to
happen yeah so it's just everybody
thought okay in one year everything's
gonna happen but it's just something
that takes time it's like it's like the
Internet of money now yeah it's just
gonna be a slow build I'm gonna sell my
apartment and put it to bitcoins mark I
were to do that make you happy if I did
that I think it'd be great I would
encourage you to do Wow why do you own
an apartment there like New York City's
like such a like you it's so great to
rent in New York City because then you
can move around you don't have to deal
with tax
the property taxes and maintenance and
why'd you hire own can I just like
knowing that if I can never ever own it
outright I'll be set somebody get fired
or if I don't work at least I don't have
to worry about a little bit of I just
like having X I can resell it and move
somewhere I just like the security or
trying to like to move around yeah you
want to downgrade if you want to have
yeah if you want to become a minimalist
you can get all your money back right
but sometimes you can't set like exactly
when you need the money that's usually
the time you can't sell so like
everybody needed the money in 2009 but
nobody could sell so that's the one
problem I have with with owning is it's
not that liquid you can't get them all
right when you need it you can't get a
mortgage or or sell it's the only worry
I have so you don't have that that thing
that some financial people do about like
when you're renting you're just kind of
throwing money away no because look I'm
paying rent but that's the same right
now I'm paying rent on a place and
that's the same that the owner is
probably paying on his mortgage and I'm
not even counting his property taxes and
his maintenance which I don't have to do
and yeah maybe in 30 years he has it
paid off but I mean while the average
person moves every four and a half years
I could just move around you can't
predict you know the price of houses so
I don't know I like being flexible I
like I look at like it's a even if you
can only sell it when you want at least
you can eventually sell it and I look at
like it's a bank like when yeah market
crashed a few years ago I had been put
on my money into my old apartment so I
didn't lose a lot of money cuz I was
yeah but people like no invest and then
you know the interest will be bit like
you're always a place to live like I get
paranoid like I like just cash and I get
afraid because this happened to me twice
where I owned a place and right when I
break got went broke I couldn't sell and
when I need it like I was about to sell
but when I first lost a ton of money I
was about to sell someone was making an
offer on this place and I would have
gotten out alive
and then I lived a block from Ground
Zero 9/11 happens of course obviously
mine is not a horrible store I compared
to the horrible stories the millions of
horrible stories about 9/11 but you
couldn't even enter my area because they
of the FBI wall around the place so it's
another year and a half before I saw
by then I was I was dead broke and the
house was worthless and the air-quality
they kept I almost put on John Street
when I first moved in the city this is
the air quality down there was bad it
might be bad for a while so they were
selling kind of cheap down there but
yeah I didn't do it I was afraid the air
quality wouldn't be good yeah that's why
we couldn't sell the place also like was
is is horrible like my kids playground
was closed down and yeah of course again
many worse things happened other than my
kids not being able to go down a slide
one thing that was one of the bad things
that happened and James called me or
emailed me recently I'm not a good chess
club an average chess player two below
average but I still love chess players
and let me come meet Gary Kasparov so
jealous that you know him ya know he he
just had this new book out so so he came
on the podcast to talk about it I knew
you you know you wanted to meet him and
you know back when we were kids he was
like rising up as the the greatest chess
player in history and so it was a fun
thing was today I got this photo you the
GZA from the wu-tang clan and Gary
Kasparov and we're just like hanging out
there I was pretty cool yeah did you get
the plan I know I played him before and
he really was unhappy about me asking
him the last time like he there's no
game for him to play me because he has
to win because that's what's expected
and if he loses I get laughing rights
forever so he has no gain in playing me
but what I did was after the podcasts
the the GZA hung out for a while and we
played speeches for about a half hour or
so so would you ask him to play what did
he say he he was a good guy about it but
you could tell it was just like oh no I
I could see it on his face
oh no I have to say yes because he I'm
on his behind but he really didn't want
to so then any plate we played he did
say yes we played I had a board o'clock
everything and but he really wanted to
make sure he won not that he had to be
that much effort but I played this
variation I've been playing since I was
18 years old and I've been crushing with
it and in tournaments since then and he
I think he like ruined that opening
forever
like I think he like demolished it and
like forever no one could ever play that
opening again he did he beat you easily
he I won't nobody could tell but like by
the 10th move I realized you know what I
can't move any of my piece
and he can move all of his I just had to
just sit there and wait and nobody
watching at all it's like Oh James is
doing good he's like lasting you know
people think of the number of moves it
shows that you're doing well I just was
I had to just wait while his pieces like
slowly crept down and surrounded me and
choked me to death like it was a joke
like I was you know struggling for
breath and rather than like a car
running me over I think he just really
wanted a torch for me right right
exactly how you didn't want to commit
suicide right right no pain felt every
bit of it right how did you enter into
the podcast world because your show the
James Altucher show events a pretty
incredible gas son yeah we'll just like
you guys you guys how did you you know
you've been doing this for a long time
and you know you just you just ask you
know I know a lot of people through my
different I sabotage everybody around me
yeah just took the see I mean that was
my strategy yeah but I I just at first I
asked all the people I knew from the
different industries I had been involved
in like whether it was writing or
finance or computers or the self-help
business or whatever and and then I just
started you you I mean you guys probably
know this too you have to ask like a
hundred people and you get like one or
two and of like you know the real hard
gets and you know how to knows but you
get a lot of non responses to I just
don't respond to the requests yeah and a
lot of times we'll just keep at it too
so I don't think that was going there
though usually you get a lot of knows
but sometimes you might get a yes you
can put it in the world of Jim Norton
you get a lot of knows and then you get
a bunch of non responses yeah you want
yes or whatever yeah yeah no you're
right you're right so so yeah we the
podcast producer I have is really great
as this guy Steve Cohen used to produce
good morning New York and CBS early
morning and he literally sends out 100
emails a day to everybody like everybody
you could possibly think of
he will just send an email to so that at
some point if they ever want to go on a
podcast this name is familiar like my
name is familiar so the Ryan asks again
and they're like okay yes we'll say yes
because sometimes we'll take three years
before I get somebody who was the first
like big guest that you had that you are
going okay this is gonna lead to more
this is gonna
you know give me the credibility that
I've been looking for Coolio
really yeah he's the number one song of
1994 gangster's paradise talking I'm a
familiar with the artist yeah and then
maybe like Wayne Dyer oh so it was like
losses last interview right before he
died and he sold over 100 or 150 million
books it was a well known mall no name I
don't know I've had like I had a lot of
people on Mark Cuban know yeah who was a
friend of mine previously but then he
agreed to come on so he was sort of the
beginning of like a string of
billionaires that came on Peter Thiel
came on as a first investor in facebook
Tyra Banks came on great yeah
Tia was just before after the Hulk Hogan
gentleman great if you get asking about
that it was before but then the guy who
wrote the book on it conspiracy Ryan
Hale that he came on to describe the
whole thing and it was because I was a
fascinating story and I just wanted Hulk
Hogan but that's just yeah yeah that's
my one time I went down to Tampa and I
visited with with Bubba the Love Sponge
sure because he was involved in some
stock and he wanted me invest so I had
you know Bob I've done a show but we've
never actually physically met I haven't
met him so we had we had dinner and he
in the middle of dinner he takes out
this gun he's like hey check this out he
throws this gun at me and it just he's
just he was kind of a crazy guy so you
could see how he could be mixed up with
that whole sure situation yeah yeah yeah
so you you've had Mark Cuban on the show
you had Shark Tank Damon on your show
yeah oh I've had all the shark tank guys
on the show and and Marcus lemonis who
does the show the office I saw that I
mean I flute because I love all those I
mean everybody here knows how much I
love shark tank but I watch the profit
like I'm trying to get Travis to start
watching the profit because it's like my
favorite show beside Shark Tank
I think he's great yeah so so I love
those like voyeuristic shows where he's
like are they gonna are they gonna get
rich or not is like Marcus LeMond it's
gonna use his genius to like make them
millions and millions of dollars so I
I've been pitching a show which is which
is it's gonna happen which takes it one
step further I'll kinda describe the
show please do sure it's called I will
make you a millionaire
and I'm just finding five random people
off this right off the street giving
them highly personalized strategies and
then very quickly as quickly as possible
turning them into millionaires so that's
that's the show and it's you know it
looks like it's look like it's cool okay
looks like it's in the middle of
happening so it's great how long does it
take you to develop the strategy with
the person almost right away from
stranger - yeah so can you develop a
strategy with me right now how do you
make me into a millionaire yeah I'd have
to develop one that involves a noose
take out a life insurance policy what
was that book had it remember that book
when we were kids like how to disappear
completely and never be found it was
like one it's like by anonymous and it's
like two million copies and it was all
these stories about people who wanted to
like leave their wives and like
disappear and and you know was all about
well here find somebody who died the
year you were you know a baby who died
the same day you were born and then get
their birth certificate and then get a
pass and and then they and then buy a
guy and live off like 50 miles off the
coast of Florida so anyway like ideas
like that still still sell what we can
do do it let me do it in John's husband
didn't hear and came and the buddy was
alive the whole time yeah dead yeah
DB Cooper that's right where is he yeah
who knows just chilling just chilling so
what so what would you need to know for
me to make me into it I what are you
what are some of your other interests
well I like doing you know I like
broadcasting obviously I'm a big pro
wrestling guy yeah so so I would I would
I would you know first with you I would
consider a bunch of things at the same
time so I would do make something like
the steroid diet okay so so here's if
you want first off if you want to be a
professional wrestler the reality is
like after you reach a certain point
yeah
they don't tell you this while you're
devoting your entire life to it the
first 15 years 20 years but then at some
point to be at the top Rank's you got a
dope in some ways so hey here's what all
the I'm just guessing by the way I don't
know right now I'm taking your word for
hey I don't know I have never watched a
wrestling wrestling match this is Terry
here's the steroids they all take in
hell but if you don't want to do that
here's how you can mimic it with
nutraceuticals and
and we'll give you all the recipes we'll
tell you what these different wrestlers
do it we'll do different interviews with
different top wrestlers about their
eating habits and eating routines I see
and and what their morning exercise
routine is and we're gonna sell that for
$10 a month then you would write to a
bunch of people who have email lists
that they you know like like Sean
Hannity let's take him as an example he
has a huge email list attends to so
you'd write a guy like him maybe not him
but there's a thousand people like him
and you would say hey I'll do a 50-50
split if I if you just say one paragraph
like oh I love you know Sam's the
steroid diet it's like changed my own
diet I've lost 30 pounds and you know
assuming that it did do that for him and
and and I and I bulked up at the same
time and I'd have to turn myself into a
bit of a muscle man though ya know yes
you know but you just just interview
like a hundred a hundred wrestlers like
my there's this guy Dan Buettner
National Geographic wrote this book
about how to live to be a hundred he's
not an expert he's not a hundred but he
just he studied all the countries where
people have a high quality life over the
age of 100 and you just becoming that
you would talk to all these people and
just put their thing down and people
would pay you $10 a month who are either
wrestling fans or want to bulk up with a
good diet and the steroid diet is sort
of like what's called a pattern
interrupt where oh my gosh what is this
is recommending steroids and people know
your name is being affiliated with
wrestling so okay I trust Sammy's a
credible source and he's interviewing
all these Peavy has access to all these
people I don't have access to so I trust
him on what he's saying here right you
do a deal with somebody who has a huge
email list already which you guys should
already have but you should you should
start developing your own email list and
then you sell for 10 20 bucks a month
which is people won't even think about
that you sell 5,000 of those out of the
50 million wrestling fans around the
world
and so you're making a hundred thousand
a month you know what's interesting I
said how do I become a millionaire and
you know what James didn't say well keep
doing radio absolutely like podcasting
like people say oh I want to get rich
doing podcasters maybe like two out of
600,000 podcasters who make a profit on
their podcast right so right it's very
difficult yeah if you do a couple ads
it's still hard to make real money oh my
god yeah that's why it's so great to
advertise on a podcast because people
no value like it's actually pretty
valuable to advertise on a podcast but
podcasters don't have the negotiating
ability yet to charge more like I wanted
to ask somebody a company I know was
saying well what do you charge for a
podcast read like giving your audience
you charge fifty thousand dollars and
I'm like no more like three or four
thousand and you know and I do it
through a middleman like that's what
they pay me and you know the economics
are just not there even though the
economics are there to advertise on
podcasts oh yeah totally
absolutely it's definitely in the
advertisers favor right now hundred
percent yeah if you guys were to read
like it with a podcast you have to read
the ad so if gymru or reading like well
I I've used you know I wear Brooks
Brothers suits every day to the salmon
Jim show right and then people from me
on Jim Norton where's Brooks Brothers
suits what and they they start going to
Brooks Brothers like and Brooks Brothers
pays almost nothing to support the plot
to get a personalized companies read are
smart they're like roots of fight like
just sends Jim and me boxes of clothes
that we love and then every photo that
you see doing and we've got roots of
fight stuff on and it's done it they
sent me stuck shout they're so sick of
the same roots of fight and I wear every
time I mean Casper mattresses they were
if Casper was a big podcast advertising
yeah they were dying to send me a
mattress but I didn't have a home so I
would I would read their ad but I would
have to say because I wanted to be as I
would say look I live in Airbnb I don't
personally use one but you know people I
know say this is the most comfortable
mattress ever are you still living in
Airbnb right now no no I have a home
yeah I have right after like three or
four years of it Wow
this this female friend of mine called
me up and said you know you got you need
to get yourself an apartment now like
you're about to be 50 and women are
gonna think this is creepy and so I just
followed her advice and I guy and also
you know I am involved with stand-up New
York the club and I couldn't it was hard
to find the air B&B on the Upper West
Side for whatever reason I don't know
why and so I had them because I wanted
to be close to where I was hanging out I
moved up there
why did you live in Airbnb for three or
four years
uh you know it's I didn't want to rent I
didn't want to own I just didn't want to
do I'm really you know MIT MIT five
minimalist yeah I was I was bit
minimalist I didn't own anything I
didn't own any possessions and except
for like maybe the clothes I was wearing
in a laptop and I just didn't want to
deal with anything like it's hard for a
human being to deal with like people you
know to write to rent an apartment in
New York you guys know this yeah you I
needed like six references and then a
lawyer an accountant bank statements
statements from ex landlords statement
from it partners and ex-spouses and then
and then I've never had a credit card in
my life so it was ever and never and so
I had I have a weird credit score and so
nobody it was it was just a drain on the
credit card no I've never I have another
car but I never had a credit card you're
not trust yourself no I just I just I'm
too lazy to it's like paperwork I can't
I can't sign well you're right because
like you hear all these stories all
these people they're like in the
business of helping people and giving
people strategies and stuff they all
want to like push themselves forward
it's like just follow my lead
I got all my [ __ ] together and I'm gonna
tell you how to get your [ __ ] together
and then you're sitting here being like
look I can come up with great ideas for
people but I don't have a credit card I
I don't know how to deal with any of
this though and also I hate all I hate
the self-help industry because
everyone's like oh here's the ten
principles of leadership tell you know
you must have like failed miserably as a
leader at some point I need to hear that
story otherwise what were you just did
you just come out of your mother's
vagina a born leader like nobody does
that like you have to go through misery
to know something you have to do things
to know things but when you have like
Tony Robbins on your podcast right and
Tony Robbins is a hundred percent you
know grab the world by the ball
seize the day the minute you wake up
he's just like ready to [ __ ] go at
all times you'll never hear him be like
oh I didn't do this cuz I just I'm too
lazy I don't want to deal with it do you
start going like oh I can't ever be too
lazy to do anything I gotta be more like
this guy no because he has he for one
thing he's gone through his own set of
difficulties as a kid i he had you know
abusive
you know he had a was living in a very
poor situation and you know he kind of
overcame that and he talks about that
and in some of his early stuff but but
also he's got like some weird store of
energy you know when I'm on the podcast
it's like I literally have to yell I
have to scream at him to shut up so that
I could ask a question like one time
he's going on
anything's yelling like and he's paying
on a table and then you know the
president called me to ask me my advice
in this and I was just this 31 and he's
talking about and I'm like screaming
talk don't you stop like why would the
president of United States call this 31
year old guy like what was he actually
asking you and you know he it kind of
like you have he has his core message
and you have to shake him out of his
clique get more specific questions
taking a real conversation going yeah
we've had him on once he's a charismatic
guy yeah you can see why people like oh
he's a big dude he's smart but I don't
understand the whole guru thing people
just thinking like I guess could they
don't show you any of the other stuff
they don't show you the weakness or the
bad parts or would they fail at [ __ ]
they just don't show that to ya and you
do see like I you know so I am NOT your
guru you just watch that Netflix on yeah
right so in you know Brian Koppelman who
and David Levine who created billions
yeah they produced that documentary and
you could see kind of like what's going
on a little behind the scenes and you
know it's it's like any mass movement
that is is dependent on a charismatic
leader now you have whether you're good
or bad you have to use those tactics to
get a message across because otherwise
just the bad winds because they're using
those manipulative tactics but then you
know at the end notes you see a lot of
the advice he gave to those people in
the show didn't really work out like
that woman got back with her boyfriend
and you know all these things happened
so you just have to have you kind of
have to use your own judgment about
what's bad which is why I never say do
this I just you know say this is what I
did and how I got through it I'll never
say you should do what I did because I
don't know that's why okay I don't know
anything about wrestling you say
wrestling and then I'm just we're just
brainstorming right diet that was a
pretty good brainstorm though oh my god
yeah like I'd buy it maybe right like if
I wanted to get in better shape in a
better diet
and I wanted to look like a Hulk Hogan
or the rock or something maybe I would
say well I would at least look what's
the steroid diet is he what is he
recommending here it sounds so strange
so when did like the the billionaires
the the Mark Cuban's of the world
when did they sort of become aware of
James Altucher was it because you early
on had that success so it's like once
you've made money people who also make
money no the other people that are doing
well um it's a little bit of both like
like with Mark Cuban in 1994 he was a
billionaire he had you know broadcast
comm when she sold to Yahoo later so we
were doing my company was doing
streaming live it was the first time any
TV show ever was streamed live while it
was being shot the People's Court with
Ed Koch 97 or 98 I forget what it was it
was in the the pen hotel at Pennsylvania
hotel I don't know if it still called
that across from you know just the worst
block in the world and more so I was
doing the website and I had to pick who
was our streaming partner and Microsoft
in broadcast comm were both both wanted
to do it and I you know broadcast I'm
really like wined and dined us and so I
I let them do it so they were the
streaming partner that we used and that
was the press release that used to kind
of launch their IPO I didn't really have
revenues was the largest IPO in history
at that time I went up six hundred
percent the first day and then he sold
for billions so I kind of
tongue-in-cheek say you know I made Mark
Cuban five billion dollars but you know
the reality is he did it all himself but
you know I kind of know him from from
that time so he likes you from a long
time
yeah and then I've kind of half worked
together on other things like he's read
articles I've written and then and then
did made the investment and proceeded to
lose money on everything I was
recommended we're still very good at
like responding he responds to anybody's
emails he's very good guy and Peter
Thiel
with him I came out in 2005 saying I'm
in the Financial Times saying nobody
should ever go to college no kid should
ever consider going to college and he
and everybody now it's a conversation
but everybody then was
crashing me and get and literally I was
getting death threats for this and Peter
teal was the only other guy saying no
nobody should ever go to college so we
kind of knew each other well from that
and also Peter teals uh about the same
ranking as me in chess so we knew each
other little from that do you still
think nobody should ever go to college
oh yeah and the sad thing is I'm my my
19 year old daughter has taken a very
dark path in life and she's going to
college like that's the way she's
rebelling against me is by going to
college I offered her I'll give you the
tuition in cash and all you have to do
is rip his watch one movie a day with me
and we could talk about it for a half
hour afterwards then you can go off and
do it everyone and if you don't go to
college and I would take the deal and I
might be right she gets that cash yeah
she has the cash like it's just 19 and I
offer this to her at 18 and I offered
this to her last week and she's like
yeah and why did I mean I like one movie
a day um because I think you learn more
from good movies you know I learned more
about the Holocaust from Schindler's
List and from from taking a history
class about the Holocaust so I think
that did I I buy the argument that for
some people the college is not the
universal that it used to be but I don't
buy the other side of the universal the
college is bad for everybody because I
think there are people they'll come out
of college kind of with the first sense
of Independence yeah I mean there's
those social aspects yeah right but you
you're gonna get those social aspects if
you're just thrown out of the house
anyway and you get a job somewhere or
you learn job skills so like if you do
anything out of the house involving
skill acquisition you're going to meet
friends and get socialize and find your
peer group and so on right like you
found that with comedy you like you to
start doing stand-up after you you know
we're 18 19 there's 21 and 21 and then
you met your your peer group and that's
the group you know now and that you
trust and support you is not it's not
anybody and you know that's sad I mean
it's gonna pop calorie-rich voss like
it's it's really actually I really did
[ __ ] throw myself into a [ __ ] pile
but but so a lot of people who do do
that with their frat brothers yeah
that's that's not that's not like the
best group of people either maybe but
I'm not making a mass judgement but but
in that and but you didn't have to take
out 200 thousand in student loans that's
true what about stuff like law school at
medical school like you have to go to
college for that or how do you get the
law like why does the law mandate that
you have to go to law school to be a
lawyer like I actually I don't do this
anymore but I used to give talks at law
firms about the law I'm not a lawyer and
but sometimes of a law firm needs some
new expertise they'd call me and for
something I'm an expert at and then I
would explain the law to them so it's
not like lawyers it's not like anybody
learns anything like I I went undergrad
computer science and then graduate
school one of the best grad schools for
computers I went to grad school for
computer science then when I had my
first job as a programmer they had to
tell me your you're such a bad
programmer we have to send you to
remedial classes every month and I had
just been programming at the highest
levels in academia for six years and no
good like wasn't good enough for the
real world translate yeah it didn't
translate if you have a dad
like James out teacher where you don't
need to worry about taking out a student
loan because your parents are gonna be
able to cover college for you right so
the expense of college is now taken out
of the equation because as an 18 year
old your parents are covering it then
like what would be the flaw if you're
gonna spend the money anyway because
you're gonna give it to her in cash and
she's like well I don't need to worry
about repaying these loans I can just go
then why would it be a negative thing
because she still wants to learn skills
and and you know learn skills and
they're in a real-world way and she
wants to succeed in life and I think
that head start of learning those skills
at 18 and I see 23 but not even 23
because you go to college so you've
graduated at 22 or 23 and maybe you go
to a little graduate school you think
you have these skills because of what
you just did so you're kind of fooled
throughout your rest your 20s thinking
you have these skills and then suddenly
there's this huge slap in the face like
oh my gosh I actually don't know
anything and then you have like 28 right
right and you have to
and I'm like well what do I want to do
with my life of Maya failure already at
the age of 28 that the average email I
get is either someone 45 to 55 who
suddenly finds himself you know divorced
and without her jobs their life has to
change completely like what do they do
or someone who's 28 and already thinks
they're a failure because the whole life
system they grew up with has failed them
and you know I don't really you know
it's not like people get a history
degree or even a computer science degree
and then suddenly like they're they're
they're good at it or what do they even
do with it so my daughter was trying to
decide should I get a degree in in
neurobiology or acting and I said
neurobiology what what is that even like
what are you gonna that's you're just
gonna read a bunch of books take a bunch
of tests forget everything who it's
gonna be outdated in a year at least
with acting you're gonna learn how to
have a bunch of skills like stage
presence and how to express yourself and
how to understand a plot and a story and
memorize things there's a whole bunch of
skill sets and acting people think it's
useless but even if you're not an actor
you can use those skill sets for so many
things so I'd encourage her to be nice
right yeah I've you I've used it to try
to convince people I didn't actually
[ __ ] him behind their back yeah let's
say yeah you know you talk about people
reaching out to you for advice let's say
I know a friend right let's say about 50
years old who's he works in the creative
arts and he on one end of the spectrum
is looking for are talking about the
autism spectrum or very possibly on one
end of the spectrum he's looking for a
relationship he's looking for somebody
who can be his companion he's looking
for emotional support but on the other
end he's just as filthy as the day is
long and I mean it is just has not has
every inch of him is pervert but
financially he's doing well and and
professionally he's doing great he is
one of the most talented and
best-looking co-hosts you could ever
imagine so talking about yourself no
I've been that across I'm not saying
this is anybody in particular I know
what needs the co-hosts
so what would this 50 year old person in
the creative arts do
in that round to get his personal life
on track do you think well I exotically
hypothetically he's probably already
doing some vent like you know getting in
shape losing weight being physically
healthy is losing weight he's gone to a
doctor is getting electrotherapy and his
penis hypothetically
he's also hypothetically exercising his
creativity you know on a regular basis
hypothetic and you know at III don't
know like I will just say specifically
what I did what was important to me was
just that I was spending more time
earlier with let's call it toxic people
than non toxic people and just it was
important every you can't make the
switch so it was it was important every
day to figure out who is would be
non-toxic for me and you know it's like
a bonsai tree trim a little bit of
what's what's a little toxic and bring
in a little bit more about what's you
know someone good for me and you know
kind of just emotionally I'm just saying
this is what I did I'm not giving any
advice like this is just a thought this
is what I had to do to kind of get on
track was just stop being around people
who are really bad for me that's
basically put in a spoonful of love
scoop out a spoonful of piss maybe stop
going to Troy for advice on isn't this
cool problem the problem is like let's
say let's say you're about to eat a soup
and there's like a tiny tiny microscopic
piece of [ __ ] in the soup no matter how
much soup you keep pouring in there
there's still a piece of [ __ ] in the
soup so you have to you have to really
you have to have like a good clear soup
without with no [ __ ] in it scoop the
[ __ ] out yeah and again I'm saying
that's what I had to do because I was
just too dependent on the advice of all
these people who who weren't that good
for me I always look at like who's dumb
soup I'm just somebody scoop all this
soup off my tree top of this dessert